hello i am abdullah from sudan born in
2004 in nyala south therefore
and on the map the western part of sudan
is where you found therefore
for over a decade the state was affected
with conflict which you were still
reeling from
and as a result since i was four years
old my family have lived in a calm for
internally explosive people
an idv come
for families that have been driven from
their homes for one reason or another
to another parts of their country
my family were displaced because of
conflict
and i was born in a world full of
complexity
loss and deprivation
but despite that
my family and i are still here full of
hopes and dreams for better tomorrow
before the camp we used to live in a
place called utah village in south
and in the world
utas comes from the arabic word atesh
which is means thursday
and it has been called so for the lack
of water resources in that area
and so the name of our idb cam is
utashkam
same name same issue
it's home to almost 100 000 people from
different villages
i was very young
when we left our home but i can remember
the fear on my family's face
as getting ready leaving everything
behind
i could see the pain especially on my
mother's face
i still remember
my family were one of the thousands of
families
that fled not everyone was lucky some
lost their lives while trying to escape
because the journey was so dangerous we
had to hide frequently along the road
where we used to live is only two hours
away
but the general took two days until we
finally reached a safe place the place
that today we call otash idbcom
during the two days it took my family to
come
we had nothing to eat and only a little
water
my baby brother died from malnutrition
and he was not even two years old
my brother's passing affected me a lot
that's why i'm decided to go to college
to study nutrition and medicine
just to help others and find ways to
prevent others what happened to him
in a world with so much food and so much
prosperity no one should ever die of
hunger
i feel like it owed to my baby brother
to be better and do better so i can help
people like us
whether from darfur or anywhere in the
world
i have big dreams and i know education
is my
past reaching them
education is
a basic right for every child
and it is a way
each of us can get skills
tools
and power to make change in our lives
and in the world
education is a basic right for all
children especially for those who have
grown up only knowing violence and
conflict
and education also is the way
we make our future
more secure and our present more
peaceful
a generation needs power to make change
and the greatest power that ever known
to all is the power of knowledge
when i read books
i feel like i am no longer in my tiny
room made of high wizard electricity in
the camp
i feel like i'm confident enough to say
that
i am the captain of my destiny
from my room in zacam i've been able to
travel through books to cairo london and
france and all the way to colombia
university in new york
and i know what most people may think
about me
that i'm an internal dispersive person
that may be true but i'm more than that
i'm patience
i'm hope dreams and with education i can
get where i want to be
education in an idb camp is hard and
utash
has certainly had its ups and downs
at the beginning there were no schools
nearby
now there are schools but they're not
always free
and we don't always have access to
electricity or access to internet like
schools in many other countries but
education should be free for every child
and access to quality education should
be a priority and available
for all the children
meanwhile
as more people in darfur have been
displaced the schools inside our camp
have become overcrowded
but still they have big dreams too
and in my state primary school exams
i came to said in the ranking out of
thousands of students
which was a huge achievement for me
soon i will take another test at the end
of my secondary school
and then i hope progress onward to
university
moving step by step closer to my
ultimate goal
along the way i've learned to speak
three languages
i speak fluently in arabic
english and turkish
and recently i
started to learn french
learning languages makes me feel
powerful as i challenge my mind
it also makes me feel i can communicate
with other people
which is important to a connected and
equitable world
and also it's one of the many ways that
can bring us all together as human
because of my academic achievement
a few years ago unicef sudan wrote an
article about me
in which i shared my biggest dream to
one day to go to columbia university and
study medicine
and now today i'm one of unicef sudanese
advocates championing the rights of a
child to access to quality education
i told you i have big dreams
since becoming
a youth advocate with unicef sudan
i've been emphasizing the importance of
peace and education
and i see how using the camp look up to
me
and how my parents and siblings whose
respite with the opportunities i have
given
which makes me feel proud
and i love seeing everyone in the camp
wants also to fight for education
recently i had the opportunity to fly to
the capital of sudan her tomb
it was the first time to me to be on
airplane
and first time also to live niall
i even had the opportunity to meet with
the prime minister of sudan
along with other youths
representing every state in sudan
which was truly overwhelming for me
i mertoom from otash idb camp was the
prime minister of sudan but also an eye
opener i connected with other youth who
came to the capital
with a heart full of hope
and a mind filled with determination
wanting to share their stories
from their parts in their country
i realized that
despite of our different cultural
background we were all one we have the
same plight and needs but we all wanted
one thing
peace and fair treatment and access to
services and opportunities and this must
be true with every child around the
globe the visit also reminded me that
there is so much unfairness in this
world
as i was lying in my hotel room with
ac on an electricity i sort of how i
struggle in the camp to study and sleep
because of lack of electricity
when i study i rely on flashlights
i can't help but ask the question why
i realized that i'm in so many ways so
lucky
because i have opportunities to succeed
in life
and i have the great privilege to
continue to increase
awareness about education for all
children like me and across the world
imagine if they were given the skills
power and
knowledge
imagine the difference they would make
in their life and in our
world they have big dreams too
education just like electricity
shouldn't just be for some it's a
necessity and a right
just like hopes
dreams
and opportunity
shining away forward for each of us and
in turn allowing us to make the world
better for others
i'm arthur abdullah from montage idv
calm
but i'm so much more than that
i say it proudly with the power of
education i can make the world a better
place
we all can thank you